[Music]
hey what up what up this is john with
the dr
john deloney show today we are talking
about having a relationship with the
narcissistic mother-in-law
talking about controlling your thoughts
and actions in a
terrible job situation and finally how
to raise a son
in a toxic masculine environment stay
tuned
hey good people i am john and this is
the dr
john deloney show a show for you
about you and with you
we are talking about your relationships
your relational iq your mental health
parenting being a good friend that
annoying
pta mom who used to just be stuck in the
school building
and now she's on zoom calls in your
living room with a
beach background all of it everything is
a b-i-n-a-n-a-s
and so if you want some truth you want a
second opinion i'm here
to talk with you give me a call at
1-844-693-3291 that's 1-844-693-3291
you can also email me at ask john
ramsey ramseysolutions.com leave your
number give me a brief description of
your question what's going on in your
life
and we will get back in touch with you
and set up a time for us to talk
so far the show is going awesome we've
got emails from all over the world
we've got calls blowing up our um
you know our our i don't know what you
call them answering machines now is that
what we call them
yeah voicemail we've got calls on the
voicemails
um it's really been a remarkable
response this is exciting time for us
and so i just want to kick the whole
show off going wow back to my home state
of texas
with brad brad good morning how are you
man
hey john thanks for taking my call hey
thanks for reaching out what can i do to
help man
yeah so i'm having issues with uh
my mother-in-law there's uh so you're
the one right going on
i'm the one you're the you're the one
so man what's going on the
my main question is is whether or not
our relationship is salvageable okay
so so my when i first came into the
picture
my wife let me know ahead of time that
her mother was never going to approve of
me
and that was going to be true with any
guy that she chose
so i kind of had some forewarning about
what was going on there
we had an okay relationship for the
first couple years of our marriage
and then it went downhill very quickly
when we packed up and
started moving away uh from where they
lived
so we now live about three hours
from the mother-in-law we almost never
communicate
with her and when we do tensions are
very high
um what are we tense about
so the main the main issue with her is
that her daughter
doesn't come visit her on a weekly basis
or call her
uh every day to talk about their lives
and is this now suddenly your fault
my wife used to call her very frequently
and it would end up leading to my
mother-in-law telling her that she's not
a good daughter
that she she's not she's not being the
person that she thought she was going to
be when she
grew up um we've i've heard her tell her
daughter that the only reason she had
kids was thought they could be there for
her
when she was older and take care of her
and
um to the to the ex to the um another
extreme
where she's threatened to do self-harm
to herself
if interactions don't continue wow so
i kind of stepped in and told my wife
that we need to not
have a relationship with a person that's
going to
try and manipulate us in that kind of a
direction how would your
and how did your wife receive that she's
she's fully on board with my thoughts
she doesn't approve of or appreciate the
way that her mother
treats her or myself we have we have a
really great relationship
um everything about the last four years
of our lives has been
pretty amazing so she's she's fully on
board with having
rational conversations with her mother
if they if they can
we've tried to suggest going to
counseling
with her mother and her mom would only
would say that we could only go to
counseling if it was a friend of hers
and on her timeline
so we we throw we threw out that as an
option
um but now it's it's getting to the
point where
when we do visit it's not about seeing
her and interacting with her daughter
she just wants to occupy time
just for the sake of occupying time but
there's no meaningful interactions it's
kind of
tense the whole time gotcha so how can i
help you man so
is there a is there a way that that we
could
approach her and try and have an
interaction with her
where we say we want to try and fix this
and go to
counseling where we can kind of get her
mind off of only going to
a person that she knows it's a friend of
hers and getting
something that's more uh more
professional based
i based on what you're telling me now no
um i i think one of the great misnomers
of our current ethos right the language
we toss around just in our communities
in our neighborhoods these days
the word narcissism gets thrown around a
lot um and i think
it's it's uh misused a lot i think most
people
are just exhausted or there's jerks or
there's people who don't have the tools
to respond to certain things
there's not a whole bunch of true what i
would call diagnosable narcissist
somebody who tells their daughter i
created you so you will serve me later
you're a bad person for not
in the blank x y or z that's somebody
who is so totally absorbed
in their planet and their universe that
everyone else is a tool
to get what they want so again i'm not
in a position to
to do diagnosis that sounds more
narcissistic than most anything i've
heard recently
and so when you're dealing with somebody
who's is a narcissist
or who is totally
absorbed in in their world what
makes them happy what makes them feel
good to the detriment of the people
around them especially to their kids
the sad reality is no there's not a lot
you can do there because everything's
going to be about control
and power and the more
your wife her daughter grows up and the
more
your wife her daughter exerts her own
independence and falls in love with a
guy like you who cares about her has her
own family her own jobs her own
her own friends the more that power
gets fiercer and tighter and sharper um
and then eventually it will move on to
something else so um
the the thing i would recommend a couple
things would be
would be this number one i would
recommend
getting with your wife and this is
this may sound cheesy or lame but i
would recommend
sitting down and having what i would
call some sort of grief um
ceremony some sort of grief process and
what we're doing here is we are letting
the fantasy
of mom's gonna be this awesome
supportive grandma for our kids someday
she's gonna like you're gonna be the
brother or the son she never had and
everyone's gonna be welcomed in
just to really sit down and let that
fantasy go
and what happens is especially with kids
is
they are grasping onto these tiny
moments these tiny glimpses because your
mom's gonna have conversations with your
wife that
are lucid and clear and she's going to
check in and say how are things going
she's going to say wow that's really
great
and it's so it's so tempting to go there
she is
there's my real mom and then to forget
all of the hurtful things and the
harmful things and the painful parts
right
and then as somebody who just loves his
wife and is tired of seeing
some other person hurt his wife it's
gonna it's gonna
cause a division with you and your wife
and so it's good to get together
get on the same page and just grieve the
loss of this fantasy
the second thing you got to do is to
recreate
or to build new boundaries for what it's
going to be
and you all decide together with some
sort of accountability we're going to
call once a month
and it's the right thing to do it's mom
and we're gonna call
once a week twice a week whatever number
is good for y'all
we're gonna visit only at christmas and
we're gonna visit for 24 hours we're
going to get a hotel
and if mom says you can't come then
we're not going to come but that's going
to be our boundaries that y'all create
on your own and then you really for a
year or two have to stick by them and
that's where you can be supportive and
you can hold your wife when she cries
because it's going to be hard
and you can be frustrated with her mom
and call your buddies or call your
counselor and say like hey my
mother-in-law's
sucks and she's beating up my wife
verbally and emotionally
but don't take that out on on your wife
because remember that's her mom
however painful it is and then in a
couple of years
it's you're gonna find new strength as a
couple
either your mother-in-law is gonna get
on board or she's not man
and that's gonna be her journey and her
battle the fight not y'alls
um if you want to go to counseling with
you and your wife to kind of create this
new world together where
you realize fantasy's over it's gone
this is gonna be the way this is
and you can invite your mother-in-law
but man forcing her to come or
there's not some magic thing you haven't
said yet
um so as i'm saying that how does that
land with you
it's kind of the direction that i
was leaning when i last talked to my
wife
on things that we need to do and i think
she would be on board with
that kind of a plan there's one
other angle and i don't know i'm not
sure if if we can go into that
go for it go for it got got a minute or
two left go for it
okay she has one sibling and the mother
has realized that she can play with my
wife by using that sibling
that sibling tells my wife that she's
not allowed to cut her mother out of the
picture
because then her sibling will take the
full brunt of
the mom and they don't want that they're
afraid that if my wife cuts her mom out
of the picture
even to the extent that you mention that
she will
have do some self-harm and
her sibling doesn't want to be the
person that has to handle that
is her sibling still living at home
no okay so her sibling has to
make those same boundaries and have
those same um
hard conversations with herself with
her partner if she's if she's with
somebody else if she's got a husband
in the picture with her it'd probably be
good for your sister and her to get in a
room and to have
unified boundary conversations if i've
got a family member who is
using self-harm as a weapon if you don't
do this i'm going to hurt myself
anytime a family member a friend
a co-worker uses that threat
i call 9-1-1 i call the police and i
call him the calvary because i'm not
going to be
beholden to somebody else using that
as a as a manipulation tool or as a way
to drag me around a neighborhood
and at the end of the day if your
mother-in-law chooses to
self-harm chooses to not get help
chooses to not accept the love that's
been extended by you
and by your wife and by her sister
on the terms that you guys put forth
right
that's your mother-in-law's decision if
your mother-in-law is not well she needs
to get help and she needs to get help on
her own
if she's got a husband still in the
picture that's his responsibility to
partner up with his wife so i i'm not in
the business of abandoning parents i
don't think that's well and healthy
at the same time i'm not in um i'm not
a proponent of kids getting abused for
the rest of their life
by folks who do not know how to say i'm
sorry
don't understand what parent-child
relationships are supposed to look like
don't understand what intimacy is
don't understand how their feelings hurt
and they weaponize those things so
um this will be a hard transition for
your wife it'll be a heart changer for
her sister
because there is one person on earth who
was put here to love
them and that's their mom and their mom
has taken that
most important thing for their brain for
their heart
for their spiritual life for everything
and weaponized it and used it as
a as a tool as a weapon so it's going to
be hard
and so i again start there start with
getting your wife out of the house
y'all go have breakfast together i say
that all the time i love having
breakfast for hard conversations but go
have breakfast
and say i love you i'm not going to talk
bad about your mom but i want to begin
creating a our own boundaries as a
couple i want us to have some sort of
miniature funeral for the fantasy that
was and i want to invite your sister to
it she can join us too because we all
need to be on the same page
and we're just not going to let mom
continue to emotionally abuse us into
our new homes into our adult life and to
our kids etc
we'd love to have her involved but at
this point she's choosing not to be
there
so man brad thank you so much for the
call um we'll be thinking about you
after you have this this mini ceremony
after you have this
funeral for the fantasy i want you to
call me back i want you to let me know
how it went i want you to let me know
how your wife's conversation
with her mom went um keep up with me and
i like to stay plugged in on this one um
this one's gonna have some tentacles to
it and it's gonna take some
some time to process but i tell you what
man
i wish i i hope that every guy listening
to this
loves their wife like you do is invested
in
having a great marriage and is invested
in
being a partner with their wife as they
wrestle with their
own baggage their own demons their own
parents trying to hurt them so
what a blessing man you're a stud dude i
appreciate you let's go back to the
phones let's talk to
sue in seattle sue how are you this
morning
well congrats on your new show thank you
so much thanks for joining us
here at the very beginning you are in on
something big right is that what you say
when you're trying to get somebody to
invest like an avon or something like
you're an early adopter sue this is this
is going to be huge for you
so how can i help what's going on well i
wanted to talk to you because you've
worked in higher ed
i have been invested in my job
for now 13 years because of the dream
of free college education for my
daughter dropped her
off and i thought i was going to feel
you know really relieved and be really
excited
but i got home and all i could think of
is
okay 45 months to go to sit through this
job that i've learned that i'm kind of
really sick of i've been in you know now
that i've been on this debt-free journey
i'm
two years away from being debt free i've
been really dreaming about what can i do
next i've been
thinking about what my other
possibilities could be
and now i'm feeling a little like
god i'm really kind of stuck in this
thing because
her tuition is tied to doing this job i
can't quit
i can't move on to a better thing and
even when i do get out of
uh out of debt i'm still going to have
to continue to do a job i i really don't
love anymore
so what do you do for um your your
school career center
i work in the career center and i work
with students and employers
so that is a thinkless challenging job
for those of you who don't know career
centers
and admissions folks and
development folks folks who raise money
those are the three positions on a
college campus
that no matter what is going on in the
world they are judged by a single number
at the end of a calendar year you either
succeeded or you failed if you're an
english professor
you are helping folks learn to write
learn to read learn to think
broadly learn to think deeply
and but there's no centralized metric
that you can post up that you have to
put up for the world to see whether you
succeeded or failed right
i was a student affairs guy so i was
always dealing with after hours things
hard things and the the
how i judged my job or how people judged
my job was
it's amorphous right it's are we helping
students learn these out of the
classroom experiences and things
a career services person
is how many of our students got jobs you
failed right
what a tough tough job i've known some
extraordinary
career services folks and they are
always under the gun there
so what part about your job you love
oh god i maybe none of it man it won't
hurt my feelings maybe none of it maybe
you're just sick of the whole thing
there i have bright spots i i think of
sending out an email message to students
about an opportunity and seeing somebody
take action on it like when somebody
actually
went through to the next step and
applied to that opportunity
and then gets the job i love that part
um
and i love being yes from behind the
scenes i have new software i can
actually tell that that happened that
is a thrill i love that piece
um and i'm actually kind of thinking i
like the
the direct marketing of those
opportunities being able to do the a b
testing of the messaging
and seeing which kind of messages they
actually respond to and
i'm loving that i'm getting to do it
virtually
and doing it jointly with other schools
i'm actually kind of excited about that
possibility
what part of your job do you hate you
just just every second you're like man i
think i'm gonna set myself on fire
just just to feel the heat like what's
what's that part of your job
oh there are
folks that i i know i have rage about
i mean like raged i had to storm out of
the office and
stop my way around a building before i
could go back and actually
talk to people um that was about uh
just dealing with regulations and uh
getting approvals to do things that just
make common sense but
i have to go through this process to
make something happen
common sense does not always drive
decision making in higher education
right
so now here's the here's the back out
here's the 30 000 foot view and i'll
simplify it for you and i'm going to put
you on the spot is that cool
yeah all right so
i want to think about this on a a couple
of hundred year scale
and then a very like right this second
scale okay
yeah if we were to back out a couple of
hundred years and think about
the and what i'm going to do is not fair
by the way and i know that so just bear
with me here
um if we backed out a couple hundred
years
and looked at the general sacrifices
people have been willing to make over
the years for their kid
for what comes next and then i fast
forward to
the absolute ridiculous challenge you
have
of a single score metric job that is
that is dependent on there's very few
things you can control
right the economy's in the tank students
can't even come in and meet with you
this a a new generation of student who
just thinks you've got a magic drawer
full of jobs right like hey i'm
graduating where's my job
and who doesn't always pay attention in
class and doesn't know how to do resumes
just
basic things um and you're judged on did
you get them a job or not right so
that's tough
but it's in the air conditioning you're
good at it you're
you can grind it out like you said for
four years and then your daughter can
ride off into the sunset or your sun can
come out from the sunset that's one side
of it
the other side of it is playing a
10-year 20-year game the other way and
the reason i
when i think about that way i think does
your kid have to go to this school
is there another school that is free in
your community
that can do community college is there a
state option
in the area where your son or daughter
can y'all can sit down
and work out the finances of it and say
i can't do this job anymore
or i've got a great opportunity i'm
transitioning but this is going to cost
us tuition and that's a hard
conversation for you to have of course
but it's also um a
remarkable moment for your kid to see
their mom thinking about themselves
planning
and the natural consequences of stuff
right so i don't think any of those
options are bad
but it's kind of an either or right that
you're going to grind it out you're
going to work really hard
um and you're going to say i'm going to
make one of those little chains and i'm
going to spend the next four years doing
this job but also
building what's going to come next like
you would tell a you know a sophomore
who comes in to see you
or yeah get an exit strategy sooner
rather than later and get out
and let your son or daughter know hey
this is this is some
this is time for me to make my move and
this is gonna mean you're probably gonna
have to change schools
yeah we we had the hardest conversations
already and she had already had to make
compromise on school she ended up badge
okay my school is part of tuition
exchange so she got to go
out of my school basically but what she
wanted to study
is not available nearby where we're at
unfortunately
okay um but i'm committed to grinding it
out
i just need some strategies to be able
to survive it without
you know wanting to kill my colleagues
and and just
be a better person in general um
because i'm committed i'm gonna have to
do the next four years and i'm gonna
have to be
sanguine about it so i would recommend
this
inside of a school ecosystem and you
know this
um if you love working with students
if you love the marketing part if you
love the collaborative
part if you like working and reaching
out in other universities
and having partnerships which schools
all across the country are having to do
right now because it is just a
sideways hurricane duty storm right now
out there in higher education there's
students everywhere they're not showing
up in some schools some schools are
canceled some schools are online all
that
so schools are having to partner
together like never before
i want to recommend that you start
scouring
your own institution for places where
you can transition inside your
institution
i want you to scour your local area
where you wouldn't have to move
where you can find opportunities that
are going to be able to jump
institutions in different positions that
will get you that will still have the
tuition exchange but we'll have several
years
i'm not a huge fan of people just
resigning themselves to the next four
years gonna be awful
um or the next four years i'm going to
have to
just suffer um even when it's for a
greater good sometimes we got to do that
and that's life
but if there's other options i really
want you to explore that
and then i want to tell you this story
that happened today and
maybe it will speak into the next four
years and this is a
a conversation not with your colleagues
not with your bosses
not with your child this is a
conversation you can have with the
mirror
so i live about 30 minutes from work i
live out in the woods
literally in the woods and i drove into
work today
and i'm notoriously behind i love
talking with people
i like just staring off into space i
like writing i was up at before
four a.m this morning trying to finish a
a book here that that we're trying to
get out
i was writing i was in the middle of it
and then i got to work
on time not on time i got on to work
before on time
which if you know me super rare i agree
i walk in
i sit down i get all my stuff out i
start to work
again on on this book
and my wife calls and says i hate to
tell you this
but our son went out to the car this
morning with my with her keys
and left them in the back of my truck
and
she had to get my daughter to school she
had to get herself to a writing event
this morning
which meant i had and i had an hour till
we went on
set this morning until we started
recording
that meant i had to race to my car my
truck jump in
drive 30 minutes the other way drop off
a set of keys
oh dude the whale guy is there and i had
to talk to that guy for a second
drop jump back in my truck drive back
here
and get here just in time for james and
kelly to say hey we're about to we're
about to go live and then we're rocking
and rolling
why'd i tell you that annoying story the
whole time
i had this well in my soul of
my stinking kid doesn't pay attention
he's just blue
through life he's like a balloon just
floating around
like bouncing off of things he's got the
greatest heart he's
brilliant he's comically smarter than i
am but he just is like
through life and i was thinking i'm
gonna set up this
and then i would stop and say no dude it
was an accident and then i'd drive
another couple of miles and then i would
think
you know what dude i'm gonna get that
kid i'm gonna tell him and then i have
to
exhale and say all i can control in this
moment
all i can control is my thoughts and my
actions
and what i have is i have an hour drive
ahead of me 30 minutes one way 30
minutes the other
i'm gonna have to get back to work go
straight into the recording studio and
get on the air
and i can be all fired up and my heart
rate can be high
and i can go bananas or i can let this
go man
i am going to have a conversation with
my son tonight i'm not going to be mad
about it he didn't do it on purpose
we are going to talk about paying
attention and i get to choose my
response to that
and i realized in those moments as i was
driving
i've been practicing this for five years
since i spent some time with a man named
randy harris there in texas who's a monk
who taught me how to be mindful who
taught me how to start
this long journey of flexing the muscles
of controlling my thoughts and my
actions
and i get to decide how i respond to
this stuff
i get to respond whether i just smile
and say
i don't know what's going on in your
life man that's not about me and so sue
i'm telling you this to tell you this
i'm telling you this to tell you this
that was a little bit redundant i tell
you that long story to tell you this
it could be that the next 12 months the
next
24 months of a really hard job a
thinkless painful frustrating job
that has a higher purpose right now you
are helping folks navigate a messy job
situation and that's a gift to have a
good career services person
you are helping your kid go to school
for free with free tuition that's a big
deal
you're setting them up that's a legacy
move on your part
but it could be a moment for you to get
with a counselor
to get with a group of women there in
your community
that say you know what we're going to
practice for the next 12 months
controlling our thoughts and controlling
our actions we're going to learn how to
exhale when somebody gets in our
business
we're going to learn how to literally
heap coals of kindness
on frustrating annoying faculty members
on jerk employers who show up late or
don't even show up at all
students who are don't pay attention and
respond to emails
ridiculous administrators we're going to
turn that corner and in 14 months
in 30 months and 40 months i want you to
circle back and say
i worked on my heart i worked on my
responses i worked on my thoughts and my
actions
and now i'm a person who can bring calm
to chaos i'm a person who can bring
laughter
to hard situations i'm just a person of
joy
because i chose to and this could be one
of those moments
uh i make fun of crossfit a lot it's a
great workout program but
just the yeah dude this could be one of
those crossfits for your soul
for the next 24 36 months and so sue
i say go for it and if you again if you
have to call your kid
in a couple of months and quit i fully
understand
i left the industry um it got big for my
heart i got too much for my soul
in a season and i was blessed with an
awesome opportunity
to um transition out but i get the
just can't do it anymore i get it i get
it i get it so blessings to you sue when
you decide what you're gonna do circle
back and give me a call i'd love to hear
how it's going
and thank you so much for the call and
let's circle back to cincinnati
encircling back i guess we're in seattle
so we're gonna go east to cincinnati and
talk to my man bill bill how are you
hey john how are you doing i'm doing
outstanding how about you
doing great great thanks for taking my
call um i want to say i'm really happy
you've been brought into the ramsey team
and i've really benefited from your
youtube videos and what you've done on
the radio so thank you so much for that
man
man thanks brother i appreciate you i'm
still figuring out how youtube works
but they tell me that if i keep plugging
away i'm going to learn how to
how to do it right so thank you so much
man so how can i help totally
well um i've been married for about
seven years and
we have a one and a half year old son so
my question is um
what are your insights on raising boys
and how
that would relate to the attack on
masculinity we are seeing these days
hmm so define number one let me back up
congratulations on having a little baby
we waited i think
my wife and i eight years seven or eight
years to have our first kid so
i remember being where you are and you
are square in the middle of it and i
want to promise you
things get awesome get there in a bit
they get awesome
um rewarding describe
the attacks what are you what are you
talking about
well you know how they just kind of in
the media and
this society is talking about
this toxic masculinity and so i want to
try and raise my son to just be
comfortable in his own skin
about being a man and obviously he's one
and a half so he's got a long way to go
but how can i as a father be encouraging
that
you know who he is is okay and being a
man
and being a godly masculine man is okay
so let me ask you man how are you
feeling attacked what are some things
you're hearing in the media what are
some things you're hearing
from people that you work with what are
some attacks you're feeling personally
that you're worried are going to rub off
on him
um give me some specifics i would say
like being the leader um
like not not dominating way over your
house or your wife or anything like that
but
as we're called to be the leaders of our
houses um
you know there's this i guess we would
say attack on that
um there's kind of it's frowned upon
that men take charge and
um are looked to as the leaders and
um being confident like a man that's
confident and bold
is frowned upon um i guess those things
and
i guess i'm kind of navigating these
waters myself too
as a you know within the past five years
it seems to be really a hot topic and so
i'm kind of trying to even
think about it and figure out like what
am i doing that
people might say is toxic and i don't
feel like i'm being toxic i feel like
i'm a nice person and
um i'm just trying to do the best i can
but
um the blinds are getting so blurred
these days
with not even just this you know um so
many things
but um especially with just being a man
and masculinity it feels like they're
blurring those lines what do you think
so man number one i want to applaud you
for the question
um and i want to applaud you for being
reflective and number two
i want to applaud you for being a dad
who's thinking ahead
so many of us get so busy so exhausted
and we just try to get to the next day
to the next day the next day that we
lose this intentionality um this
moment where we can just pause whether
we're driving or removing the yard or
whatever and just to think
man what kind of world is my son
inheriting and what can i do right now
to to participate there okay so exactly
here's a couple of things so i live
in the mental health world and the apa
the american psychological association
put out a paper
and maybe in a year or two three years
ago on toxic masculinity
and if i was to sum it up in my own
language here's how i would distill it
down
the things you mentioned about
leadership
confidence taking charge
domination i think the reason
those words have got a bad rap
is because those things have been used
those mantras those feelings those those
actions have been used to
abuse people to hold hostage people
and to really get people's way
you used a really really important word
that if you can
leave this phone call with that if the
listener can leave this phone call with
i will feel like i've done my job for
the next six months
you said um
not i don't want my son to feel like he
is over
and that is the main word when i think
of toxic masculinity
for whatever that means for whatever
different group right
i think of the difference between over
versus
with and so if i was to distill down
what i think toxic masculinity looks
like
is that we force our boys to prove their
worth
they do not understand at an early age
that they have inherent
value just because they're people just
because they're beings just because they
are worthy of being loved
we set them up in conquests and in
contests
to when you do these things then you
will prove your worthiness when you do
these things
then you will be worthy of fill in the
blank
being a leader being a husband being a
man being a whatever
this idea that the bigger arms win
and often in nature that's the way it
works right the bigger lion
right like wins man and i think
the the challenge there is we look
around at our communities we look around
at our country and if we look back the
last hundred years
the attack from folks who have not been
in power right
are looking at it and saying hey guys
y'all have always been president
hey guys y'all have always run the
finance system hey guys y'all have run
fill in the blank of institutions
churches
um schools whatever and every one of
those institutions is a mess right now
and so if i have a a job right if i've
got a business that i'm running
and the the business is a mess the buck
stops with the leader
and so as a guy i am balancing two
things right now
number one this idea of right what does
a head of a household look like what
does leadership look like
leadership does not look like head of
household does not look like
i get 51 percent of the vote i'm more
powerful
i'm stronger i get to decide what i'm
training my son who's 10 now
is leadership means you get underneath
everything and hold it up leadership
means you go
last leadership means if there is a
fight to be had you go
first you are the first one to be on the
front of the line
and when people are eating or people are
showering or people
are in need you go last and so this idea
of
not the leaders eat the nicest the
leaders eat what's
left and so it's this idea of submission
and that is a reframing of masculinity
for me
another thing is this idea of being with
i want my son to know
that when he is married when he's got
kids
when he is a community leader when he is
a boss when he is a coworker
his job is not to look for people to
have dominion over
it's to look to people to have
relationships with
and the most effective way um we say it
here at ramsey solutions i work for dave
ramsey here
um business moves at the speed of trust
and trust
is is is fostered around a table where
people eat together they communicate
they hang out together
it's when people are with now somebody
who's in charge
um the boss if you will the buck stops
there right somebody's got to make a
call and that can be man
and woman i report to amy who reports to
jeremy who reports to suzanne who
reports to dave right so i've got
two women i think i've almost always had
women leaders throughout my career
the buck stops with them right so
whoever's the boss boss but
that's less about gender and more about
position um so when it comes
all the way back to it i'm talking a lot
to just to say this i want
my son to know he's got value
that he is allowed to feel feelings that
he is allowed to
love deeply that he's allowed to use
words and ask
for hey dad can i have a hug i want him
to know that he is
valuable just because he exists
and i want him to teach i want to teach
him to use his strength
use his he is a monster dude my son i
don't
i think my wife is injecting him with
roids on the weekends dude he's huge
i want him to um use his
physical position he's a big kid i want
him to use that
wisely and boldly and strongly
and also not to empower and i mean not
to
overpower and crush people but to serve
people right
so that's my that's my spiel on
masculinity
um how does that ring true in your heart
when you hear it
that's great i mean definitely a lot of
good points to
reflect on um i really liked especially
what you said in the beginning about we
sometimes put
the earning mark on
our voice that if you do x y and z or we
expect you to do
whatever good at football or win the
sports game or something like that and
then
you're you're doing your job then um
tearing down that wall
and just loving them for who they are
and not getting caught into that trap um
that's a great insight i think and
here's the other thing that you're just
gonna have to hold close to your heart
and that is this um
i say this often and it's just a good
saying to put in your back pocket
and it's not by my hand but in my lap
you are a guy raising a young son
in a cultural mess we owe too much money
we're having to deal with racial racial
reconciliation
that we have swept under the rug and not
dealt with for years and years and years
and years and years
we are dealing with international
challenges we are dealing with weather
challenges i got family in houston right
now waiting for the second hurricane in
like a week to come through
um we've got fires raging in california
and colorado i mean things are a mess
and it's just been dropped in your lap
in this little snapshot in history
and so people are going to talk bad
about you just because you're you
and you get to decide am i going to
carry that baggage or i'm going to
set it down i'm going to work really
hard to be a good guy in my home
to be a good man in my community in my
neighborhood to listen
when i feel like someone's hurting my
feelings i want to lean in and say what
can i learn from this and the rest of
them is going to put that nonsense down
and raise a son who knows how to love
who knows how to speak up for himself
and who knows how to serve and protect
his community
and service comes from underneath and
behind man and if you get on that track
if you can teach him to hear what he
needs to hear and to
not carry other nonsense bricks down
everyone's going to be throwing rocks at
you man
regardless of what it is you do they're
going to throw rocks at you for who you
are for what you want to be for the sun
you want that's just going to be life
man
it's happened throughout history and it
will always happen
i want to know where i my values are
grounded
i want my son to know he's loved i want
my daughter to know she's loved my wife
to
to know she's loved and i want them to
see it and feel it in me not just words
they got to hear that too but
see it and feel it and brother bill the
fact again i want to reiterate this the
fact that you are already thinking this
through
as a dad of a one and a half year old
man blessings to you brother you are way
way way ahead of the curve and so as we
wrap up the show today
it's a big deal to me that we go back to
some of the great poets of our time
right these folks who are songwriters
who are imaginative
who know how to think who know how to
take heavy
hard concepts and bring them down
into these little sonnets right these
little these little
stanzas a couple of stanzas and a chorus
and that's why
every show we in with the song lyrics of
the day
today is a shout out to my buddy trevor
who back in college introduced me
to me pro not maybe easily the greatest
songwriter
in the history of the world who wrote
i mean i'm going to say this is the best
song ever written period
at full stop this is from his 1971
record
mudslide slim and the blue horizon
this is the great james taylor and the
greatest song ever written
you've got a friend it goes something
like this
when you're down and troubled and you
need a helping hand
and nothing oh nothing is going right
just close your eyes and think of me and
soon i will be there
to brighten up even the darkest night
your darkest night winter spring summer
or fall
all you've got to do is call and i'll be
there
yeah you've got a friend
this is the dr john deloney show